[Música]
porque la baguette como lo estábamos
conversando también con Daniela Blandón
obtuvo el estatus de patrimonio
inmaterial de la humanidad de la UNESCO
una noticia que se vive con júbilo por
supuesto en París donde está nuestra
periodista Erika olavarría Erika la
saludo muy buena tarde buenas y
deliciosas tardes para usted ahí ya está
con esa vagué Yo todavía no he
desayunado y qué hambre verla con esa
deliciosa bagueta encuentra justamente
en una de estas deliciosas panaderías de
la capital Erika no
sí efectivamente se la mando si quiere
por avión hacela por favor regalar un
euro 20 vale aquí la baguette y no queda
mucho hasta ahora porque son acá las dos
y cincuenta de la tarde y lo que me
explicaba aquí nuestra amiga valerie que
es la artesana panadera es que ellos las
preparan para que estén calientitas para
los clientes Entonces la gran hora es la
mañana el mediodía y ya en la tarde
cuando la gente sale del trabajo y viene
a buscar su baguette vamos a conversar
justamente con ella Qué tal vale
ella dice que es algo que tiene que
quedar en nuestra tradición y que tienes
que ser Guardado de generación en
generación roosemont Valery sé o sin
rincones
la tradición
tradición cotidiana
porque lo que está salvada guardando la
UNESCO Raúl es primero este trabajo este
oficio de panadero artesanal porque ojo
la baguette tradición no tiene aditivos
dado un decreto pero también
salvaguardar una una tradición cotidiana
los franceses que ir a comprar el pan
que si se
piensa usted de esta salvaguarda de la
oficio de la panadero
dice que es un trabajo difícil que hay
que salvaguardar pero que también es un
trabajo que tiene mucho amor y que está
en peligro justamente y leo entonces se
metía por la industrialización
[Música]
yo le digo Cuáles son esos peligros la
guerra el covid han afectado obviamente
lo que es la administración de una
panadería en Francia lo decían en la
economía cuatrocientas panaderías menos
cada año Cuáles son esos peligros
su actitud
justamente ya nos dice que sus costos
son aumentados o se han multiplicado por
tres y no quieren pasar ese gran costo
al pan a los clientes finalmente si no
saben cómo van a superar esta crisis
yo lo tengo una última pregunta no sé si
la puede hacer a Valery y es que con
esto que estamos viviendo El día de hoy
cree que a lo mejor nuevos y jóvenes
panaderos artesanos se pueden animar
entonces pues a hacer su negocio de esta
bagueta artesanal para sí evidentemente
incentivar a los jóvenes y salvaguardar
todo esto
Mira la pasión
ella dice que Claro que sí además que
hay muchos programas también de
televisión que hablan de los pasteleros
la pasticería que se dice en Francia y
también de la bulachería O la panadería
por lo tanto ella cree que sí porque
esto es un amor sobre todo lo que
mantiene este